we're hearing from the widow of a
decorated New York City firefighter
killed while serving in Afghanistan for
the first time since his death Staff
Sergeant Christopher [ __ ] Minh was one
of three Marines killed by a Taliban
bomb this month CBS Evening News anchor
Jeff Glor spoke with flatlands Widow and
two men who fought fires with him ahead
of his burial at Arlington National
Cemetery when Christopher [ __ ] Minh was
killed by a roadside bomb in Afghanistan
he was three weeks away from going home
one of his best friend's was a fellow
firefighter and Marine Kevin McGowan I
just wanted him home
everyone wanted him home everyone missed
him and I just I you know I feel selfish
about saying that but man I couldn't
wait until he got home this week people
lined overpasses and highways in three
states to watch Chris's casket ride back
from Dover Air Force Base he'll be
buried in Arlington on April 30th
surrounded by hundreds of firefighters
and family including his daughters ages
10 8 and 4 and his wife of 13 years
Shannon my husband was constantly a
gentleman she is speaking publicly for
the first time since Chris's death on
April 8th I do better when I'm busy
evenings are hard once I have my girls
in bed and it's just me and my thoughts
it's hard do you talk to him oh yeah
he's he's always with me Shannon isn't
the only one still leaning on Chris I
just say hey but don't let me screw this
up I gotta take care of your family
because I just need to honor him by
making sure that the girls know that
their dad was the greatest man I've ever
known
he's an individual who always wanted the
next challenge Stephen Moore was Chris's
fire captain
he felt he hadn't done enough by serving
the city of New York for 15 years here
in the fire department he also wanted to
go serve his country overseas and he did
today
Chris's uniform and nameplate remain up
at the latter 27 firehouse in the Bronx
he's always gonna be here you know your
family your we're never going anywhere
whether you like it or not but it
doesn't matter if there's gear hanging
here it doesn't matter what it is he
gave this firehouse a gift
and it's here forever if everybody could
experience the type of love that I've
had the world would be a better place I
mean when we say that Chris was all-in
he was all-in in anything he did and I
have years and years and years of
stories to tell our girls so that they
don't forget how blessed they were to
have him as a dad and for me to have him
as a husband we want to thank Shannon
Kevin and Steve for speaking with us we
also want to thank Chris and all those
who serve and sacrifice remember to
other reservist also died in this
incident in Afghanistan on April 8th in
what is America's longest war it's it's
great that that he has all that if that
family has all that support from those
firefighters Shannon says she's trying
to she's trying to laugh as much as she
can now because when she's not laughing
she's crying but she tells little girls
when they're upset that in the future
when they have to make decisions and
it's a tough one there's a little angel
on your shoulder and the person telling
you to do the right thing the right
thing is your dad yeah nobody nobody
knows how to handle these things
nobody's prepared for them and to see
them act with such grace and to it's
just an amazing piece to bring us and
there is no right way and that's what
she's trying to tell the kids - is that
what you're feeling is okay you're gonna
feel happy you're gonna feel sad you
know sometimes the kids see somebody
laughing around mom or whatever else and
they're like why that why are they
laughing your daddy daddy died and you
know she tells them that it's okay we
have to have those moments sometimes -
and you still have to be kids as well no
I think about that that line that his
friend said - 15 years and he's didn't
think you didn't think he did enough
didn't think he did enough so he joined
the Marines he was serving his City one
of the service country - and his family
thank you Jeff it's an important
reminder - about people are still
sacrificing for every day every day
thank you Jeff sir